kung i-rotate mo ang isang bola sa paligid ng isang axis pagkatapos ay sa isa pa hindi ito kapareho ng paggawa ng dalawang rotasyon sa reverse na pagkakasunod-sunod
ngayon sa Qiskit in the classroom makikita natin kung ano ang kaugnayan ng bola na ito sa mga quantum computer at isa sa pinakasikat na
prinsipyo ng quantum mechanics ang uncertainty
principle maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the classroom isang video series kung saan binibigyan natin ng kahulugan ang isang pundamental na konsepto na
maaaring matagpuan sa isang Quantum Computing related na kurso ang bawat video ay sinasamahan ng isang interactive na module na naka-link sa
paglalarawan sa ibaba kaya siguruhing tingnan iyon ngayon pinag-uusapan natin ang Heisenberg uncertainty principle kung
narinig mo na ito dati maaaring narinig mo na rin ang lumang biro tungkol kay Heisenberg isang araw hininto siya habang nagmamaneho at tinanong siya ng pulis do you
know how fast you were going sumagot si Heisenberg no but I know exactly where I am ito ay medyo katulad
ng Heisenberg uncertainty principle sa maikling salita hindi mo maaaring sabay na malaman ang posisyon at momentum ng isang particle
nang may ganap na katumpakan madalas itong isinulat tulad nito ang Delta x * Delta p ay mas malaki
kaysa o katumbas ng h/ 2 kung saan ang Delta X at Delta P ay ang
mga kawalan ng katiyakan sa posisyon at momentum at ang H ay isang maliit na pundamental na constant sa quantum mechanics
Nagmuni-muni si Heisenberg ng inequality na ito noong 1927 nang iniisip niya kung paano susukat ang posisyon ng isang electron kung
itinataboy mo ang isang photon dito upang makita kung nasaan ito ang Photon na iyon ay hindi maiiwasang mapapalayo ang electron at maggagambala sa nito
momentum hindi lamang ito isang pahayag tungkol sa mga sukat na nagggagambala sa isang sistema sinasabi nito sa atin na may mga pundamental
na limitasyon sa kung gaano kalaki ang ating matututunan tungkol sa kalikasan ito ay isang halimbawa ng isang mas malawak na prinsipyo na tinatawag na complementarity na
nagsasabi na ang ilang mga aspeto ng kalikasan ay hindi tugma sa isa't isa at hindi maaaring mapansin
nang sabay-sabay halimbawa ang mga Quantum object ay minsan kumikilos tulad ng mga particle at kung minsan tulad ng mga alon
ngunit hindi mo maaaring sabay na maobserbahan ang parehong gawi ang relasyon ng posisyon at momentum ni Heisenberg ay sumasaklaw lamang sa isa sa
maraming hanay ng mga complementary na katangian ang likas na kawalan ng katiyakan na ito ay may kaugnayan sa kung paano natin tinitingnan ang katangian tulad ng
posisyon at momentum sa quantum mechanics sa halip na isipin ang X at P bilang mga variable o intrinsic na katangian
na pag-aari ng bawat particle sa quantum mechanics ang posisyon at momentum ay mga operator hindi sila mga katangian ng isang
sistema kundi mga bagay na maaari mong gawin sa isang sistema ang pagkatuto tungkol sa posisyon ng isang particle ngayon ay nangangailangan sa iyo na magsagawa ng isang
operasyon sa sistemang iyon at gumawa ng sukat ang operasyong ito ay maaaring makaapekto sa kinalabasan ng iba pang kasunod
na mga operasyon bilang isang paghahalintulad isipin ang isang piraso ng tuyong kahoy mayroon itong maraming katangian tulad ng
posisyon laki hugis mayroon din itong katangian ng pagiging maaari itong sunugin at lumulutang sa tubig kung ang kahoy na ito ay isang
Quantum object ang mga ito ay hindi magiging mga katangian na maaari mo lamang malaman a priori sa halip sinasabi nating sila ay
mga observable mga bagay na maaari mong matuto tungkol sa sistema kung magsasagawa ka ng ilang operasyon sa ito kaya kailangan mong ilapat ang pagsusunog
na katangian ng pagkasusunog o pag-float na mga operator na mangangailangan ng aktwal na pagtatangkang sunugin ang kahoy o ilagay ito sa
tubig upang makita kung lumulutang ito ngayon ang kinalabasan ng bawat isa sa mga operator na ito ay nakasalalay sa pagkakasunod-sunod ng iyong pag-apply sa kanila kung
una mong sinubok ang kakayahang masunog masusunog ang kahoy sa abo at hindi mo maaaring subukan kung lumulutang ito ngunit kung sinubukan mo ang
lumulutang muna pagkatapos ay masyadong basa na itong masunog sinasabi natin na ang kakayahang masunog at
lumulutang na mga operator ay hindi nagko-commute ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga operasyon ay mahalaga ito ay humahantong sa isang pundamental
na limitasyon sa kung gaano kahusay ang dalawang observable na ito ay maaaring malaman tungkol sa piraso ng kahoy dahil hindi natin masabi nang sigurado kung ito ay
maaaring masunog o lumulutang nang hindi nalalaman ang konteksto ng sukat na iyon ngayon siyempre sa isang aktwal na piraso ng kahoy maaari mo
itong gupitin nang kalahati at subukan ang parehong mga katangiang iyon nang sabay-sabay ngunit hindi mo magagawa ang gayon sa isang Quantum particle ang
paghahalintulad sa kahoy ay paghahalintulad lamang ang kawalan ng katiyakan ay natatanging Quantum na bagay ang X at P ay hindi rin nagko-commute
at ang katangiang ito ng hindi pagko-commute ang nagdudulot sa Heisenberg uncertainty principle sa pangkalahatan ang anumang dalawang operator
na hindi nagko-commute ay magkakaroon ng kanilang sariling uncertainty principle ang pangkalahatang anyo ng uncertainty principle ay maaaring
isulat tulad nito ang Delta a * Delta
B ay mas malaki kaysa o katumbas
ng 12 beses na may a at b kung saan
ang bracket na ito ay tinatawag na
commutator at iyon ay katumbas ng pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng pag-apply muna ng a pagkatapos ay
B at pag-apply muna ng B pagkatapos ay a ang mga angle bracket na ito
ay nagpapahiwatig na kinukuha mo ang tinatawag na expectation value ng nasa loob nito karaniwang kung ginawa mo ang parehong
sukat nang marami maraming beses ang expectation value ay ang average na halaga ng lahat ng mga sukat na iyon ngayon
aktwal na susubukan at bebe-berifikahin natin ang uncertainty principle na ito sa isang IBM quantum computer titingnan natin ang tatlong iba't ibang
observable ng isang qubit ipapakita na ang kanilang mga operator ay hindi nagko-commute at pagkatapos sa wakas ay mapapatunayan natin na ang
uncertainty principle ay nangangapit para sa mga observable ng qubit na ito una ang isang maikling paglayo tungkol sa isang nakatutulong na paraan upang i-visualize ang quantum
state ng isang qubit maaari itong katawanin ng isang vector na nakaturo sa ilang lugar sa isang sphere na tinatawag na Bloch sphere tinakpan ko
ito sa isang nakaraang video na naka-link sa paglalarawan ngunit magbibigay lamang ako ng isang mabilis na recap dito narito ang
Bloch sphere ang bawat vector ay parameterized ng dalawang anggulo na Theta at F
ang state zero ay nasa North pole at ang state isa ay nasa South Pole at ang isang pantay na superposition ng 0 at isa ay
nasa Equator kung saan ang f ay katumbas ng relative phase sa pagitan ng dalawang bahagi ng
superposition kaya ang state na ito dito ay katumbas
ng 1 / square root 2 zero + e sa i 1 kung saan ang i ay ang
phase na iyon kapag sinusukat natin ang isang observable ng qubit ang resulta ay laging isa sa dalawang opsyon na katumbas ng dalawang
posibleng state ng qubit para sa eksperimento na ating gagawin titingnan natin ang tatlong observable at
ang kanilang katumbas na mga operator na X Y at Z kapag sinusukat mo ang alinman sa mga observable na ito makakakuha ka ng alinman sa plus isa o
minus isa na may probability para sa bawat isa na nakasalalay sa anggulo sa pagitan ng vector ng qubit sa Bloch sphere at
ang axis ng sukat gaya ng inaasahan ang Z ay sumusukat sa kahabaan ng Z axis ang X sa kahabaan ng X
at ang Y sa kahabaan ng y ngayon tandaan na pinag-uusapan natin ang mga observable dahil sa isang Quantum
system hindi na lang natin maaaring malaman ang mga bagay tungkol sa sistema nang hindi sinusukat ang mga ito
at ang bawat observable ay may katumbas na operasyon dahil ang mga sukat ay nangangailangan ng mga operasyon maaaring hindi halata ngunit
lumalabas na ang mga operator na katumbas ng bawat isa sa mga observable na ito na x y at z ay
mga rotasyon ng Pi sa paligid ng kani-kanilang axis kaya ang X ay isang rotasyon sa paligid ng X ang Y
sa paligid ng Y at ang Z sa paligid ng Z kaya upang makita kung nagko-commute ang mga operator na ito o hindi maaari nating suriin kung ang mga rotasyon
sa isang sphere ay nagko-commute kung nagko-commute ang mga ito ang uncertainty principle ay hindi mag-aapply at maaari nating malaman ang X Y at Z tungkol sa isang qubit
nang may ganap na katumpakan kung hindi sila nagko-commute makakahanap tayo ng bagong uncertainty relation para sa qubit panoorin
ang punto sa bola na ito habang ino-rotate ko muna sa paligid ng X at pagkatapos ay sa paligid ng y natapos ito
dito ngayon subukan nating gawin ito sa reverse na pagkakasunod-sunod kaya iro-rotate ko muna sa paligid ng Y at
pagkatapos ay sa paligid ng X natapos ito doon kaya tiyak na hindi sila nagko-commute nangangahulugan ito
na hindi natin maaaring sabay na malaman ang eksaktong X Y at Z values ng isang qubit magkakaroon tayo ng isang
uncertainty relation lalagpas tayo sa mga detalye dito ngunit makakarating tayo sa tatlong iba't ibang uncertainty
relation kaya mayroon tayong Delta x * Delta Y
na mas malaki kaysa o katumbas ng Z ang Delta y Delta Z ay mas malaki kaysa o
katumbas ng X at ang Delta Z Delta X na mas malaki kaysa o katumbas
ng Y kaya ang product ng anumang dalawa sa mga kawalan ng katiyakan na ito ay laging mas malaki kaysa o
katumbas ng expectation value ng ikatlong observable gamitin natin ang Qiskit upang makita kung ano ang
mangyayari kapag sinubukan nating sukathin ang parehong Z at X ng state zero ang pagsukat ng Z ay madali ito ang tinatawag na standard basis
ng quantum computer ang mga sukat ay laging nasa kahabaan ng Z bilang default ngunit upang sukathin ang X kailangan nating magsagawa ng tinatawag na isang
pagbabago ng basis karaniwang ini-rotate ang Bloch sphere upang ang X ay nakaturo pataas kung nasaan ang z dating nakaturo upang gawin ito
gumagamit tayo ng Hadamard gate kaya ang buong quantum circuit ay magmumukhang ganito sinusukat natin sa Z inilalapat ang Hadamard
at pagkatapos ay sinusukat sa X kung gagamitin natin ang Qiskit primitive sampler upang patakbuhin ang eksperimentong ito nang maraming beses makakarating tayo
sa isang histogram ng mga kinalabasan ng sukat na nagmumukhang ganito para sa Z
sukat at ganito para sa sukat sa X kaya gaya ng makikita natin nasukat ang
qubit na nasa zero state sa kahabaan ng Z na may halos 100% katiyakan ngunit
sa kahabaan ng X halos wala tayong alam tungkol sa state ng qubit nasukat ito bilang alinman sa zero o isa na may pantay
na probability nangangahulugan na ang ating kawalan ng katiyakan sa X ay halos kasing laki nito maaari nagbibigay sa atin ng
kaunting kahulugan para sa trade-off ng mga kawalan ng katiyakan ngunit kaya nating gumawa nang mas mahusay sa ating quantum computer maaari tayong gumamit ng isang
Qiskit primitive na tinatawag na estimator upang mahanap ang mga expectation value ng ating mga observable na X Y at Z at ang
kawalan ng katiyakan sa bawat isa subukan natin ito para sa state na nakaturo sa plus X direction sa Bloch sphere gagamitin natin ang estimator
upang kalkulahin ang mga kawalan ng katiyakan sa x at z para sa state na ito at ang expectation value ng
y sa state na ito nakakakuha tayo ng resultang ito mula sa Qiskit kapag kinuha natin ang product ng dalawa
na mga kawalan ng katiyakan sa X at Y nakikita natin na gaya ng inaasahan ito ay mas malaki kaysa sa absolute
na halaga ng expectation value ng y ngunit ito ay para sa isang partikular na state lamang gusto nating matiyak na ang inequality na ito ay
totoo para sa lahat ng state ng qubit kaya gamitin natin ang estimator muli ngunit sa pagkakataong ito hihilingin natin dito na i-scan ang mga halaga ng isang
parameter at upang mahanap ang mga expectation value sa bawat solong parameter value na ibinibigay natin dito ang parameter na gusto nating
i-scan ay ang anggulo na Theta sa Bloch sphere upang masuri natin ang inequality para sa lahat ng state ng qubit na nasa
arc na ito na tumatawid sa XZ plane kapag ginawa natin ito makakakuha tayo ng plot bilang function ng anggulo na Theta ang pula
na kurba ay ang product ng dalawang kawalan ng katiyakan at ang orange na kurba ay ang expectation value ng y gaya ng inaasahan
ang product ng mga kawalan ng katiyakan sa x at z ay mas mataas kaysa sa expectation value ng y ngunit hindi iyon
masyadong mahirap na matugunan ang inequality dahil ang expectation value ng y ay napakababa na zero para sa lahat ng state sa
arc na ito gawin natin ang katulad na pag-scan sa pamamagitan ng mga halaga ng Theta ngunit sa halip na mag-scan sa XZ plane itakda natin ang f na katumbas ng pi/
4 kaya tinitingnan natin ang mga state ng qubit na nasa ibang arc sa sphere dito nakikita natin na ang inequality ay
sinubukan nang kaunti pa dahil ang orange na kurba at ang pula na kurba ay mas malapit sa isa't isa ngunit ang pula ay laging nasa itaas ng orange
at ang uncertainty principle ay nananatiling totoo hindi pa natin nasuri ang lahat ng state ngunit umaasa akong nagsisimula ka nang maunawaan
ang ideya ay may pundamental na hindi maaaring malaman tungkol sa anumang dalawang complementary na aspeto ng isang Quantum
system kabilang ang qubit na ito na ginagamit natin pinipilit tayo ng uncertainty principle na harapin ang katotohanang kahit gaano
kahirap nating subukan kahit gaano katalino ang ating mga sukat hindi natin kailanman malalaman ang lahat nang may ganap na katumpakan
walang lulusot dito talaga kung hindi mo ako pinaniniwalaan o kahit pinaniniwalaan mo ako hahamon kita pumunta ka at tingnan ang module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan at subukang talunin ang uncertainty principle salamat sa panonood at hanggang sa muli